salut ce soir c'était des hallucinations
collectives vous savez le plateau que je
fais une fois par mois et pour cette
édition l'édition numéro 6 j'avais
invité un magicien qui s'appelle tao
c'est un mec qui mélange la magie le
kung fu vous l'êtes réduit sur un gros
talent et vous savez ce que je fais
maintenant quand j'ai réussi avec moi je
le fais bosser à ma place
savita aux bons soins tout le monde
merci fabien de m'inviter chez toi est
ce que tu peux me faire un tour de magie
je ne suis pas accompli c'est évidemment
sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt je me mets
derrière vous comme ça vous allez voir
avec mes yeux tu sais je sais que vous
les connaissez tous les tours de cartes
mais ce qu'entre 24 quelque chose
d'original c'est facile pour aller voir
la caméra ces petits sachets c'est un
sachet de méchant mais c'est ce que du
sucre et du voyage s'est bien passé
fabien oui tu t'en vas venir en
attendant c'est parfait on va le faire
plusieurs choses à une carte rapidement
cassé quand tu m'as reds jusqu'en tue le
temps comme ça les deux mains prises
stop
marc était bon ils remontent comme ça la
caméra d'accord aujourd'hui pas là car
je la lis partout il n y pas de même
vainqueur aura tous des amis voilà ta
personne même si j'ai fait un simple ami
sur youtube est à vienne ils sont ils
sont mouillés partis sont légions dieudo
regarde pas seulement le dakar parce
qu'il ya des miroirs qui sont qui sont
derrière toi toi bien se décider son
état est en jeu mais juste que je vis
ici à l'intérieur
pourquoi ces sachets de sucre tout
doucement on y adhère jv façon fixe en
slow motion
tapotez s'est vraiment passé un poil de
chien me met alors en gros plan vous ne
pouvez rien c'est l'appel clause morale
dans ce même klose aller vers le haut
alors pourquoi ces sachets de sucre et
bien parce que il ya une recette de
grand mère qui dit que normalement on
peut prédire l'avenir dans du marc de
café
et comme ici au théâtre il n'y a pas de
café on va prendre juste le sachet de
sucre qui avait tu as même après le jeu
fait tout du goût parce qu'il faut
déchirer le sachet je pense si tu veux
je te laisse le faire au caire et a
délicatement
je voulais juste tombé jusqu'à la taille
notamment à bien parce que je peux te
faire passer le briquet oui on regarde
je me sers bien pour pas que le sucre
est plus échapper le côté j'aime être
juste un petit peu de sucre qui
remplacera le marc de café
ok ça fume c'est du véritable sucre mais
bon ça va comme ça
parfaitement c'est bon je suis tellement
des justes dans un premier temps de
penser à la valeur si c'est du pic du
coeur du xiii vous le coeur c'est bon je
pense qu est donc plus que simples
effets secondaires la valeur juste un
petit peu du sucre voilà neuf ans et je
pense que c'est une carte base donc ça
suffira pas que j'aurais juste voulu que
je sache est tu peux me faire des gros
plans j'en ai plus besoin est mais non
si tu pense fortement à la carte du
briquet va me servir tout simplement à
chauffer un peu la matière car si je
prends le briquet je chauffe plus en
dessous pas trop où est ce que c'est
pour ça que j'avais déjà marqué au bout
d'un moment pas du tout eu un lancement
tu peux prendre le briquet s'il te plaît
la surprise tu te souviens de la
symbolique d'état car tu peux nous le
dira juste à symbolique coeur c'est du
coeur il ya financement de massy on
chauffe un peu la matière ça permet que
la matière le sucre se solidifie ici
mais je pense qu'elle va voir si tu as
besoin
si on regarde bien que ce qu'est leur
pari mais non je sais que c'est du coeur
car c'est toi même qui va faire une ag
qui attendront tama quand ça va bien
c'est donc film bientôt ma voiture c'est
pas très étonné ou du bout des doigts là
c'est bon là il ya d'autres dons mais de
mal a justement dit de fermer
thomas dossevi c'est très bien bien fort
bien pensé fortement vraiment à la carte
entièrement j'y pense je ne dois pas
faire et bien sûr le talent des doigts
dans un instant tu vas ouvrir les mains
comme un magicien doigt par doigt mais
avant ça tu peux nous dire entièrement
la guerre que tu choisisses et leucate
de coeur tout doucement pour sûr c'est
la crise effectivement une carte faible
vous n'avoir rien vu on sait que c'est
du coeur mais exactement essayé on voit
bien qu'il s'agit là d'un tekken 4
coeurs exact je sais que pablo petite
part applaudir ce qu'il ya les caméras
bravo merci à toi j'ai bien écouté oui
c'est vrai j'applaudis en direction de
l'écran où est ce que la bénéfique qui
secoue le deuxième effet kiss cool ou la
gare juste pour terminer tu évites du
passé
jeter dans le coeur ici mais bon
vraiment te prouver que tu as choisie
c'est vraiment le cas de coeur on faire
autrement c'est je prends le sucre mais
je me sens pas mal comme ça ok j'ai mes
l'autre main dessus
d'accord mais juste le sucre ici et là
une réaction chimique qui va se passer
car en parle généralement minecraft
malgré une coupe et une loge stack une
quartier alors la lounge tombé pour la
première ce que c'est le hockey sur
glace n'importe quelle gare oui mais pas
besoin tu t'en sors bien il a sans
plaque comme du coup on regarde bien la
réaction chimique qui va se passer grâce
de sucre si j'enlève cas ici
l'impression je sais pas si on va voir
la caméra que toutes les cartes sont
devenus trop moyen de varier mon jeu
comme tout l'écart devient et si tu
rentres en charge toutes les cartes une
carte une carte et une seule comme par
hasard est actée si le cas de coeur et
pas n'importe lequel car c'est pour
faire de ta pub si tu retournes la carte
pour le mental commercial merci merci
bravo et merci de ton invitation vous
bien j'espère que ça vous a plu
c'est pas trop long si jamais trop long
ces cinq minutes qu'elle savait des
mauges est allé le limoger vous pouvez
retrouver là haut sur sa page facebook
je vous mets le lien dans les
commentaires vous pouvez le suivre
et puis c'est la deuxième fois que tu es
sur les hallucinations collectives c'est
pas la dernière vous pouvez le retrouver
abonnez-vous à la chaîne c'est très
important et rendez vous demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mentale blog
châu